welcome to Hannity we begin tonight with
the Fox News Alert we're now tracking
multiple major breaking stories
including an absolute bombshell
development from the Department of
Justice Fox News now reporting that the
Durham Barr investigation into the
origins of the Russian witch-hunt is
expanding Fox is reporting at this hour
quote mr. doar has expanded his
investigation and is adding agents
resources according to multiple senior
administration officials the timeline
now has grown from the beginning of the
probe through the election and now
includes a post-election timeline
through the spring of 2017 up until when
Robert Muller was named the special
counsel and as we have reported on this
show doormen bar have spoken with
multiple officials from the UK Australia
even traveled to Italy all in an effort
to determine if the most powerful tools
of intelligence were used against our
own citizens for the purpose of
illegally spying on American citizens of
course to circumvent American laws and
constitutional protections by the way
that would be like FISA abuse
premeditated fraud I hear one of the
saddest things for my sources tonight oh
they're worried if they can get a
conviction in DC that shouldn't matter
should it the law is the law was it
verified or not verified now we'll have
answers to a lot of these questions
coming that officials circumvent US law
outsourced surveillance and the other
sense on Americans to allied spy
agencies in other words you do this for
us and then this way we're innocent in
the Trump campaign were they targeted by
our own government agencies to bolster
Hillary Clinton and hurt Donald Trump
why was Muller appointed in the first
place and according to another breaking
fox news report tonight Muller was in
fact pursuing the open FBI director job
when he met with Donald Trump in 2017 as
the president's been saying he didn't
get that position and just a short time
later he was investigating the president
who passed him over for a job that would
raise serious conflict of interest
concerns not to mention his close
relationship with the man that Trump
fired mr. sue
Patriot Jim Comey and by the way what
will the Horowitz investigation uncover
about super Patriot himself a McCabe and
struck and many others who willfully
committed fraud against the FISA Court
now imagine if any of you committed a
premeditated fraud on a court and you
signed the document an application for a
warrant take away the rights of an
American citizen back door into the
Trump campaign so you could spy in his
campaign and as later as transition team
and then later the presidency let's play
this game at home do you think you would
get away with any of that says verified
you know you didn't verify it that's
premeditated fraud on the court then
when you've know that you lied to the
court you're supposed to go back and
tell them I just have a funny feeling if
it happened to anybody in this audience
you'd have a pre-dawn raid like manna
for didn't Roger stone and I've been
saying this for a while but what we
witnessed in 2016 from our government
the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in our history now the truth is
going to come out big question I have
tonight well they hold their own
accountable I have sources telling me
tonight they might be afraid to do that
with a full report on all of this is a
very old catherine herridge tonight
Catherine he's Sean and good evening a
senior administration official confirms
to Fox News that the investigation into
the genesis of the 2016 FBI Russia
collusion case is expanding based on the
findings of US Attorney John Durham
appointed by Attorney General William
Bar and made the investigation now has
global reach with Durham recently
traveling to Britain and Italy to pursue
surveillance leads as well as working
with Australian authorities the
investigation also adding more agents
more resources for an expanded time line
which now stretches from the spring of
2016 to may 2017 when the president
fired FBI director James Comey and then
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
appointed special counsel Robert Muller
based on my two decades covering
intelligence and law enforcement the
expanded durham probe indicates that he
has found evidence that likely points to
criminal wrongdoing by reputation durham
is not a prosecutor to ask for more help
if there is simply no there they're
separately administration officials tell
Fox News there is new scrutiny of the
Moller
pointment coordination between
Rosenstein and muller in the days before
the announcement as well as allegations
Rosenstein offered to wear a wire and
secretly record the president which he
has publicly denied multiple
administration officials tell Fox News
that when Muller met with the president
on May 16th 2017 he was indeed pursuing
the post left open by the firing of
Comey a week earlier and they say newly
released records back up the White House
account during his congressional
testimony on the Russia probe Muller
said he was not applying for a second
term as FBI director he said he was
there to offer the president input on
the required skill Sean all right
Catherine Herridge in Washington tonight
thank you also tonight we're no longer
going to refer to this ongoing political
witch-hunt
the latest witch hunt on Capitol Hill is
any type of real impeachment inquiry it
is not this is just the latest attempt
at coup of a duly elected president by
we the people over misconduct that does
not exist yet again let us be clear they
never accepted the 2016 election results
they never accepted four separate
investigations no Russia collusion that
instead was a coup attempt so now they
went from one fishing expedition to
another fishing expedition Russia Russia
Russia that coup attempt then it was the
tax return coup attempt then it was the
stormy stormy coup attempt now it's the
Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine coup attempt
that's all this is they could not accept
the will of the people insane obsessive
compulsive psychotic witch hunts rooted
in rage and and a lack of connection to
reality that they lost same goal let's
impeach a man oh we have a lot of ways
we can impeach of Nancy Pelosi says left
they've been plotting impeachment of
this president from the very beginning
the moment he was elected will remind
you
if he takes the risk of going to trial
he's convicted that could be seen as an
impeachable offense I don't see how that
wouldn't be an impeachable offense an
official impeachment inquiry of
impeachment inquiry impeachment and
impeachment impeachment of the house
impeachment impeachment inquiry
impeachment article of impeachment of
impeachment he doesn't understand the
gravity of the impeachment impeachment
war the impeachment impeachment if new
developments on the impeachment inquiry
impeachment an impeachable listen
peaceful of impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment will be on the
Democrats agenda impeachment we are
introducing articles of impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeach this
president the I word impeachment the I
word impeachment the I word impeachment
the I war the I word and impeachment
let's take a look at the process of
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment do
impeach or impeachment impeachment he
would have been impeached all of it
bringing impeachment back to the for all
that may be in features well that's an
impeachable offense is that an
impeachable offense is that a
impeachable offense to you he's much
more vulnerable to impeachment
impeachment impeachment peaceable
patient and PhD treats impeachment
articles of impeachment
there should be an impeachment inquiry
opened and they are talking impeachment
started two days after the president's
election the hysteria that we see over
Ukraine that's just the latest coup
attempt the latest chapter what has been
three long years of Lies conspiracy
theories to take down a president well
that they never want elected in the
first place and did everything they
could do to prevent them from winning
also breaking moments ago White House
Counsel has issued a letter to House
Democrats formally announcing the Trump
administration will not cooperate with
the unconstitutional invalid baseless
inquiry because of three distinct issues
first the inquiry is constitutionally
invalid
violates basic due process rights and
separation of powers there has been no
vote to authorize this witch-hunt
inquiry and that means no due process no
ability for the president's lawyers to
cross-examine witnesses no ability of
the president's lawyer to call witnesses
no ability to enter evidence into the
record instead all we got was
a press conference from yes speaker and
name only Nancy Pelosi and the cowardly
shifty ship this is unprecedented and
it's unconstitutional letter also goes
on a state quote the invalid impeachment
inquiry plainly seeks to reverse the
election of 2016 and to influence the
election of 2020 according to the White
House Council the effort to impeach
President Trump without regard to any
evidence of his actions in office is a
naked political strategy that began the
day he was inaugurated and perhaps
before I would argue before impeachment
is never to be used as a political
weapon only as a check against treason
bribery high crimes misdemeanors and
that brings us to the third issue that's
raised by the white house counsel quote
there is no legitimate basis for your
impeachment inquiry instead the
committee's actions they raise serious
concerns that would be like the Cowardly
shift making up something in a
transcript that didn't exist or they
announced the impeachment hearing so we
got a variety of options if there's no
quid pro quo there Democrats claim the
inquiry is about so-called a so-called
whistleblower non whistleblower account
of a phone call between President Trump
and the president of Ukraine
well the inquiry inquiry was announced
before Democrats even saw the transcript
of the call or did they hmm
what did Schiff know and when did he
know it he now is the lead investigator
and running this committee he would be a
material fact witness in this case
wouldn't he that would then cause him to
have to recuse himself by the way was a
perfectly appropriate conversation with
the president we have the transcript no
need for non whistleblower
whistleblowers and the government of
Ukraine has said the call was totally
appropriate the US Department of Justice
has said the call was appropriate the US
ambassador to the European Union said
the President did nothing wrong the
special envoy to Ukraine kurt volker
testified under oath behind closed doors
no quid pro quo no misconduct no nothing
and let's not forget the transcript has
been released for everybody to see
we don't need a non whistleblower
whistleblowers account and their
feelings
their political bent on any of this
here's what congressman Lee Zeldin had
to say about this very issue that was
earlier today let's take a look maybe
you should ask what was said inside a
Volkers deposition during his
transcribed interview with regards to
atom shifts fairytale quid pro quo
charge that aid from the United States
to Ukraine was being a linked to an
investigation into the Biden's why do
you ask what did ambassador Volcker say
about that that's a great question I'm
glad that you asked that question and
I'll tell you the reason why that
question was so important for you to ask
it's for many things because he was in
this room for several hours and during
several hours of testimony he talked
about how president Solinsky had no idea
that there was a hold on aid at the time
the July 25th call ambassador Volcker
taught testified about how the readouts
of the phone call that was made to him
that he had that there was nothing in
the readouts about there being a hold on
us aid or a quid pro quo and by the way
you know what else ambassador Volcker
testified to this entire time the aid
was getting released it was going to get
released and guess what happened
the aid got released and you know what
didn't have to happen there was no new
investigation had to get created this
whole thing is a fairy tale Adam Schiff
is misleading you and you're playing
along with it when Adam Schiff said for
example that President Trump was asking
President Solinsky to manufacture dirt
on the Biden's you know what ambassador
Volcker testified to that was absolutely
untrue and for weeks the Cowardly Lion
Adam Schiff well he wanted you to
believe President Trump threatened to
withhold USA to Ukraine if it didn't
investigate Sleepy creepy crazy Uncle
Joe 303 300 and his son's shady Ukranian
business deals and four-week shift
stenographers the media mob breathlessly
reporting about Trump Ukraine quid pro
quo and yet again it was one big giant
hoax another lie another conspiracy
theory three long years one witch-hunt
after another one coup attempt after
another tonight we have brand new
evidence proving beyond any shadow of a
doubt the left's hysteria is once again
built on another
bed of lies investigative reporter John
Solomon has acquired documentation
showing that a new investigation was
open by the country's prosecutor general
four months before the phone call with
our president and the new and the
Ukrainian president szalinski under
Ukraine's prior president and that's not
all John Solomon reporting also tonight
one focal point of the investigation was
whether any of the 3.4 million dollars
in proceeds that parisa Holdings paid to
Hunter Biden's firm between 2014 and
2016 came from illicit sources this
happened months before the phone call in
question which is by the way huge but
there's even more we have brand new
details about the non whistleblower
whistleblower Byron York reporting
tonight he or she had a professional tie
to a twenty20 Democratic candidate that
means that he or she worked with or for
one of the Democrats that is running
against Trump would be a conflict of
interest - especially when they're
giving hearsay evidence in the first
place let's recap non whistleblower
whistleblower registered Democrat clear
political bias professional relationship
with one of the 20 20 Democrats who want
to beat Trump his complaint based on
hearsay not first-hand knowledge and
also media reports doesn't even matter
what his complaint claimed but as we
know now through the transcript what was
said and what wasn't said don't we by
the way the call in question shows no
quid pro quo nothing no funds were
withheld from Ukraine Ukrainian
officials didn't even know the president
was considering delaying aid at the time
of the call and they didn't know till a
month later and two top diplomats in
Europe said the president did nothing
wrong but then you got the cowardly Adam
Schiff a known congenital liar then you
got Nancy Pelosi another liar who has
lost all control over her party in the
house they want to boot a duly elected
president from office for nothing what a
coup and an attempt that every Democrat
must go on record about and he's so
called by the way these so-called
in other words the Democrats that live
in districts that Donald Trump won in
2016 they don't speak out against this
unconstitutional attempted coup and
witch-hunt they would be complicit in
this sit-in what is an illegal attempt
to override the will of the American
voter now there is real corruption and
government abuse of power and a quid pro
quo we actually have on tape that would
be Jo 303 303 of Ukraine because as the
media mob tries to ignore that brewing
scandal Senator Lindsey Graham he is now
invited the former New York City Mayor
Rudy Giuliani to testify before Congress
about his lengthy investigation and
don't forget we learned from Politico
what do we learn
oh yeah Ukraine was helping Hillary and
they were involved in election
interference in 2016
yeah and Jo well he shook down Ukraine
and said you got six hours you fire you
fire that prosecutor oh I'm taking my
billion dollars our billion dollars
American people's billion dollars and
I'm going home you're not gonna get it
and holy wow they fired him and he
bragged about it